what is the Hackman group and there's
Stargate fans why should we care welcome
to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a movie
channel
[Music]
so a couple of months ago now I found
out about the Hackman group talking to
one of the sources I do over Amazon and
MGM he was telling me that actually
Culver Studios they're now home for
Amazon Studios is owned by the Hackman
group the buildings that Amazon now use
is their headquarters for the studio was
built by the Hackman group especially
for them and the six down stages that
Amazon now use is their first and their
actual only stages and were also
specifically built for them by the
hackerman group
I have been digging into them ever since
and I found out some very interesting
information
the Hackman group actually are now the
largest individual owner of Studio space
in the world they own 4.3 billion
dollars worth of media real estate
literally all over the world they are
developing several projects right now
either by themselves or with partnership
with others including a massive
multi-billion dollar project to develop
the bridge Studios the place where
Stargate was filmed
they also very recently bought the
Vancouver film studios they've also
recently bought two of the larger
studios in Ireland they're also
developing the Greystone media campus in
Ireland which is a 300 million dollar
development and they already own 120
sound stages and they are currently
developing a further 90. now my source
has been able to tell me that many of
the 90 new sound stages that Hackman are
currently constructing are actually
being earmarked for Amazon
now you know that we've been talking an
awful lot on this channel about how
Amazon are actually looking for a
partner to do a lot of the Stargate
Robocop and all these other projects
mainly because they don't own enough
Studio space of Their Own
so they were talking to people like
Warner Brothers or even Sony who do own
massive Studio lots and they were hoping
to actually do a partnership with them
to create the new Stargate shows now MDM
have actually done this in the past a
couple of seasons of Stargate Atlantis
for example were actually filmed in
partnership with Sony most of Amazon's
current projects are actually done in
partnership with somebody else MGM have
been doing the same for decades because
they actually sold their Studio space to
Sony it actually became what we now know
as Sony Studios the Creed movies that we
recently had for example were done with
partnership between MGM and Warner
Brothers
so it was assumed that that's what they
were going to do and that was the plan
now my source at MGM is saying there has
been a little bit of a change in
Direction and Amazon are looking now to
maybe move forward with things like
Royal cop and Stargate without a big
Studio partner there's a couple of
reasons for this one the strikes
basically they mean that everything has
been put back about it's probably six
months at least so anything that they
were hoping to announce this summer and
they were hoping to announce a lot has
been put back probably at least until
Christmas maybe even later some analysts
are saying that these strikes may not be
over until the spring so that has been a
massive delay but Amazon apparently are
taking advantage of this delay because
their long-term goal was always to get
enough Studio space to start acting like
a proper Studio they actually want to
make their own stuff they don't just
want to slap Amazon exclusive or Amazon
Prime logos on things they actually want
to make it one of the reasons why they
spent eight and a half billion dollars
on MGM in the first place is because
they want to be taken seriously as a
studio and currently they're not so all
of a sudden because of this relationship
with the Heckman group they have access
to a massive amount of Studio space and
new studio space that's being developed
all the time and apparently their plan
is to buy the summer of sort of 2024 to
actually have 40 to 50 sound stages and
apparently according to my source about
15 of those sound stages have been
earmarked for MGM products now that's
obviously not just going to be Stargate
and RoboCop but it's very very possible
that at least a few of those sound
stages will be exactly for that I was
told a few months ago that apparently
Amazon's plan is to get hold of maybe
two or three three stages that they will
basically have as the Stargate home that
those will be where the movies the TV
series everything Etc will be made
together that that is in a very
efficient and very cost effective way of
actually producing Stargate
and that literally the actors can just
walk across the road and appear in a TV
series I'll do a spot guest on something
they can share props very easily they
can share Studio space they can share
the actual sets but this very ambitious
plan is only possible because of their
relationship with the Hackman group now
so who is the heck of a group so they
are a private Equity Firm they're a
company that basically didn't exist 15
years ago but now as I said are the
largest single owner of private media
real estate in the world and having a
little bit of a dig into them I've been
able to find out that one of their
investors actually is Amazon Amazon do
own quite a large stake in this
Development Fund so it looks like they
have found a back Doorway to getting as
much Studio space as they want
now getting Studio space is not a cheap
Affair and actually Amazon will not own
any of this space they are going to be
renting it from the Hackman group now
this is done for business reasons tax
purposes and actually it's a very Savvy
way of doing it because you've got to
remember Amazon has come from a
background of behaving in these ways
they're a business at the end of the day
now you could argue that maybe they
don't have long-term Ambitions if
they're not willing to actually lay down
routes actually buy land
but that's just not the way a company
like Amazon thinks it's all about money
it's all about how do they save money
it's not necessarily about a long term
it's necessarily about the next quarter
the next 12 months the next five years
but they're definitely 100 have a
long-term plan in this area they want to
be taken really seriously as a studio
and they are making very fast moves to
do that this is a company that 12 months
ago didn't own any Studio space at all
they now have a headquarters that was
specifically built for them six sound
stages including Sound Stage 15 which
has the world's largest actual digital
sound stage in existence and they're
already producing stuff for themselves
that is already an amazing jump but in
the next 12 months they could be doing
10 times more
so that is why you should know about the
Hackman group that is why it's important
for a Stargate fans because they are the
way we're going to get Stargate really
simply and maybe quite quickly
but guys I'd love to know what you think
is this business stuff interesting I
find it quite interesting I like the
practical ways and I quite like you know
hopefully seeing what Amazon are going
to do next I find it interesting but do
you or you know is this a quick skip it
video for you I'd love to know but more
importantly what do you think about
Amazon's plans and what do you think
that it means for franchises like
Stargate and RoboCop is it important
that Amazon actually get hold of as much
Studio space as they can to allow them
an MGM to actually start making things
themselves I honestly think that
sometimes too many cooks spoil the broth
and Amazon being able to do a lot of
this on their own
if it's successful at least they've
tried and if it's a failure well at
least they can only blame themselves
I'd love to know exactly what you think
in the comments
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and
don't forget to follow some of these
links to the scrolling across the bottom
they're all in the description
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
oh